des écoles fermés au moins jusqu'au
lundi 8 mars 1200 élèves de chambourcy
sont concernés par la mesure 13 cas
positifs aux variants sud africains ont
été détectés depuis le 12 février
dernier des adultes comme des enfants de
l'école maternelle au collège
si on prend par exemple l'exemple du
collège andré deram qui est con un
collège à vocation intercommunale
puisque la moitié des effectifs et quand
bruce yam et l'autre moitié hors jeu
relais de surcroît l'ensemble des
enfants de chambourcy vont au lycée pour
dans les lycées de saint germain en laye
et on peut imaginer assez volontiers
qu'il puisse y avoir des contaminations
dans les deux sens contagiosité plus
rapide et plus forte
effet peut-être encore méconnu un
week-end de dépistage a été organisée
sur la commune
avec cette action la rs espère pouvoir
isoler plus vite les élèves et le
personnel éducatif
l'objectif c'est d'aller vite et de
venir voir vite ce qui se passe sur
cette commune et puis le bassin de
population pour qu'on puisse prendre des
mesures supplémentaires si c'est pas
suffisant et si on a un virus qui tourne
encore plus que ce qu'on pouvait
imaginer plus de 1100 personnes ont été
dépistées durant deux jours bien que je
n'aie aucun symptôme je pense que il
faut quand même c'est heavy il ya eu des
cas dans les codes de notre fils donc du
coup on était pour se rassurer aussi et
puis étant professionnels de santé aussi
retournant au travail voilà pour éviter
de contaminer tout le monde elle la
municipalité a également commandé 600
tests salivaires pour les élèves de
moins de 11 ans